le cru est ce que vous l'avez eue au
téléphone dernièrement aérien oui mais
qu'est ce que vous dites c'est mort je
l'appelle alors l'afutt
il a peut-être laissé vieux s'appelle
adrien voir s'il a refait sa vie on va
gestion d'amber j'ai nommé roger numéro
de mon père ça sonne première sonnerie
je rappelle qu adrien joue pour se
rabibocher
adrien c'est cyril hanouna mon chéri ça
va on a en direct est ce que tu nous
regardes adrien babeau mon chéri battu
voix bah écoute tu fais comme toute la
france
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je te dis a pas de secret je suis avec
une personne que tu connais yd il doit
nous donner moi mais donnez-moi un lot
des moyens dit mais moi mélodies adrien
je te sens déjà très en forme
tu as fait ton histoire tu peux prendre
castaldi avec toi merci
il va faire comme jamais club adrien
déjà j'aimerais sarralbe ça fait huit
mois que l' aventure s'est terminée
adrien déjà est ce que toi tu fais de la
muscu pour séduire une personne avec qui
tu es en bail et que tu as peut-être en
ligne de mire
ou bien tu es peut-être déjà avec une
personne ou bien peut-être tué 100
personnes tuées dans le désert et tu te
dis il vaut mieux que ce muscle car
peut-être que je vais devoir bien
entendu gravir ddb 19
forcément quand on est dans le désert
alors qu'est ce que c'est alors discret
je veux dire il se compliquait ty ou
bien tu es libre compliqué ça a été
compliqué d'accord est d'accord façon je
veux dire tu as beau fixe et les règles
au final c'est compliqué c'est pas de
moi c'est le dadou
à
adrien mon chéri juste tu as eu beaucoup
beaucoup de demandes bataille beaucoup
beaucoup de succès à la suite de
l'émission bat parce que voilà donc la
serre éclaté extrêmement demandés et
forcément c'est comme 118 218 quand il
ya beaucoup de demandes de
renseignements parfois on renseigne et
aveugle compliqué alors professionnels
est-ce que tu as encore des sentiments
pour mélodie à temps parce que tu peux
le répéter ce que tu n'y es logement
mais sans trace sous un tunnel
c'est définitivement terminé ses morts
c'est dead est ce qu'ils pensaient est
ce que tu penses à elle parfois
alors pourquoi toi tu connais bien
mélodie est ce que je pense qu'elles
pourraient être séduites par jean michel
maire mais je dois disparaît sur port
oui jean michel a craqué pour mélodie
ils apprennent il va toucher pendant
quelques temps et un peu cher les
alouettes qui passe quoi il ne fera pas
avec des mélodies sont donc là tout de
suite d'accord t'as bien sûr très bien
en tout cas quad rien mais l'odyssée de
la page s'est tournée d'accord très bien
joué merci j'ai pris votre requête
tondeuse d'accord merci merci beaucoup
merci d'avoir fait appel à nous adria je
te fais des gros bisous et tu as mon
numéro maintenant c'est bien sûr et si
tu as trop de demandes n'hésite pas bien
entendu contacté je ferai suivre à jean
michel maire mais si c'est mon nom alors
juste une mélodie très vite
est ce que jean-michel peu de ton style
est ce que jean mi mais il faut
apprendre à le connaître mais déjà déjà
non physiquement déjà ce que c'est oui
ou est-ce que c'est non eric lamaze jean
michel aulas dit pas mal gens me choque
ça veut dire que c'est bon c'est dans la
joie me permettre
mais non magnéto elle elle lui a dit
qu'il fallait à discuter ça plus
approfondie entre les mains après
l'émission bat donc mélodie vous allez
faire connaissance actuelle on va suivre
tout ça et peut-être que vous serez
bientôt mariée au deuxième regard
[Applaudissements]